♪ ♪
>> Sean: NOW WE HEAD BACK TO
THE REPULSIVE POLITICAL STUNT
FROM BETO O'ROURKE WHO
INTERRUPTED A VERY IMPORTANT
BRIEFING ABOUT UVALDE AND THE
SHOOTING THAT TOOK PLACE AND HE
WAS THEN CONFRONTED BY THE
CITY'S MAYOR.
WATCH THIS.
>> EXCUSE ME.
SIT DOWN.
YOU'RE OUT OF LINE AND IN
EMBARRASSMENT.
>> AFTER EL PASO.
>> SIT DOWN.
>> RIGHT NOW, AND YOU ARE DOING
NOTHING.
YOU ARE OFFERING UP NOTHING.
>> YOU NEED TO GET THE [BLEEP]
OUT OF HERE.
>> THIS IS TOTALLY PRODUCTIVE.
>> YOU'RE OUT OF LINE.
YOU ARE OUT OF LINE!
PLEASE LEAVE THIS AUDITORIUM.
I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU'RE A SICK
SON OF A [BLEEP] THAT WILL MAKE
THIS A POLITICAL ISSUE.
>> [INDISCERNIBLE].
>> [BLEEP] LIKE YOU, WHY DON'T
YOU GET OUT OF HERE.
>> Sean: HERE WITH MORE AS THE
MAYOR OF UVALDE, DON MCLACHLAN
WITH US.
MR. MAYOR, FIRST, OUR SINCERE
APOLOGIES, LOVE, PRAYERS, AND
THOUGHTS ARE WITH YOU AND YOUR
ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
WE ARE SO SORRY THIS HAPPENED TO
EVERYBODY THERE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US IN
THIS TOUGH TIME.
I WANT TO ASK YOU FIRST AND
FOREMOST ABOUT THAT MOMENT.
WHERE THEIR FAMILY MEMBER'S THAT
LOST LOVED ONES IN THAT ROOM AT
THAT TIME?
>> THAT I DON'T KNOW.
THAT I DON'T KNOW BUT THAT WAS
NOT THE TIME OR PLACE TO HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION.
IF HE WANTS TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION, THAT'S FINE, BUT
TODAY AT THAT CONFERENCE WAS NOT
THE TIME OR PLACE TO DO THAT.
>> Sean: BUT THERE WERE
PARENTS THERE, THERE WERE PEOPLE
CRYING I UNDERSTAND, PARENTS AND
THE AUDIENCE, IS THAT CORRECT?
>> YES, THERE WAS.
YES THERE WAS.
>> Sean: WHEN HE FIRST SAW
THIS, AND OBVIOUSLY YOU TOOK IT
UPON YOURSELF TO STAND UP AND
TELL HIM TO SHUT UP AND I THINK
RIGHTLY RESONATED WITH A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY BY CALLING
HIM AND S.O.B.
IT'S A CLEAR POLITICAL STUNT BUT
EVEN BEFORE WE KNEW HOW MANY
PEOPLE HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN KILLED
IN YOUR COMMUNITY, ALREADY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
HAD SPOKEN OUT ABOUT THIS AND
POLITICIZED THIS, AND I HAVE A
HARD TIME UNDERSTANDING WITHOUT
ANY KNOWLEDGE OR EVEN DEATH
COUNT IN A TRAGEDY LIKE THIS,
WHY PEOPLE RACE AND RUSH TO
POLITICIZE IT.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> FIRST AND FOREMOST, ARE
HEARTS ARE BROKEN.
MY HEARTS ARE BROKEN FOR THESE
FAMILIES THAT LOST THESE
CHILDREN AND WE WILL COME BACK,
BUT THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
EVERY TIME WE HAVE ONE OF THESE
IT'S A POLITICAL DEAL.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE GROWN MEN
WE ELECTED TO REPRESENT US IN
CONGRESS THAT CAN'T SIT DOWN AT
A TABLE AND COME TO A
CONCLUSION?
I'M NOT GOING TO GET 100% OF
WHAT I WANT, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
GET 100% OF WHAT YOU WANT BUT
NOBODY WANTS TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION.
IT'S EITHER GOING TO BE MY WAY
OR THE HIGHWAY.
AND WE KEEP POLITICIZING THIS.
AND YES, WE HAVE A GUN PROBLEM,
SURE.
DO WE NEED TO EXPAND BACKGROUND
CHECK?
POSSIBLY.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEM THAT NOBODY WANTS TO
ADDRESS AND MAYBE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY SIGNS TODAY FROM THAT YOUNG
MAN BUT COULD HAVE BEEN THERE
TWO YEARS AGO THAT WE COULD HAVE
REACHED OUT AND GAVE HIM SOME
HELP?
WE WILL NEVER KNOW THAT.
19 FAMILIES, 21 FAMILIES ARE
SUFFERING.
>> Sean: MR. MAYOR, 4,598 KIDS
HAVE BEEN SHOT AND KILLED IN THE
UNITED STATES SINCE 2019.
THE SMALLEST PERCENTAGE OF THEM
ARE SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
I'M A BELIEVER THAT GOD CREATES
EVERY HUMAN LIFE AND EVERY HUMAN
LIFE IS PRECIOUS AND WE NEED TO
PRESERVE AND PROTECT IT.
AS FAR AS SCHOOL SHOOTINGS
SPECIFICALLY GO, I THINK THE
TIME HAS NOW COME WHERE WE MUST
PROTECT OUR KIDS THE WAY WE
PROTECT HOLLYWOOD STARS AND OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS HAVE ARMED
SECURITY WITH THEM.
IS THAT A POSSIBLE ANSWER FOR
EXAMPLE IN YOUR COMMUNITY?
>> WE FORMED THE POLICE -- WE
FORMED THE POLICE DEPARTMENT --
FORMED A POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THANK GOD THERE WAS ONE THERE --
ONE THERE WHEN HE WAS.
WE NEED TO PUT ARMED SECURITY
GUARDS AND ARMED POLICE OFFICERS
IN OUR SCHOOLS.
>> Sean: I THINK IT SHOULD BE
MANDATORY AND I THINK OUR
CHILDREN DESERVE WHAT OUR FOR
EXAMPLE D.C. ELECTED OFFICIALS
HAVE, AND BY THE WAY, WE PAY FOR
IT AND I THINK IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
I THINK WITH GOT TO PROTECT OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS I'M A BUT I
ALSO BELIEVE WE GOT TO PROTECT
OUR CHILDREN ALSO.
AND I ALSO BELIEVE THAT WE ARE
NOT DOING A GOOD JOB -- YOU
KNOW, HERE UVALDE IS GETTING
LECTURES FROM POLITICIANS AND
THE VERY SAME PEOPLE THAT IGNORE
THE VIOLENCE IN CHICAGO AND
BALTIMORE AND D.C. AND L.A. AND
NEW YORK, I DON'T REALLY THINK
YOU NEED LECTURES FROM PEOPLE
HAVEN'T CLEANED UP THEIR OWN
BACKYARD.
WHAT DO YOU THINK TO
>> I AGREE WITH YOU TOTALLY.
I'VE SPENT SOME TIME IN CHICAGO.
I SPENT THREE MONTHS THERE WHEN
I WENT THROUGH A CANCER
TREATMENT AND EVERY WEEKEND IT
WAS 10-15 DEATHS.
YOU CAN BUY A GUN IN CHICAGO,
YOU CAN'T BUY BULLETS IN CHICAGO
BUT YET LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENS
THERE EVERY WEEKEND.
IT'S A TRAGEDY.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS -- WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THESE SHOOTINGS, WE NEED
TO ADDRESS A LOT OF THINGS, BUT
THE GUN-CONTROL THEY ARE
TALKING, THAT'S NOT GOING TO
STOP THESE PEOPLE FROM GETTING
THOSE GUNS, THEY ARE GOING TO
GET THEM HOWEVER THEY WANT.
WE NEED TO COME TO THE TABLE,
SIT DOWN AND COME TO SOMETHING
IT'S GOING TO WORK FOR
EVERYBODY.
>> Sean: MR. MAYOR, I KNOW YOU
HAD YOUR VIGIL TONIGHT AND I
KNOW IT'S BEEN A VERY EMOTIONAL,
YOU KNOW, TUMULTUOUS, YOU KNOW,
48 HOURS, 24 HOURS FOR THE
PEOPLE IN YOUR CITY.
WHAT IS -- WHAT IS -- WHAT ARE
THE PLANS FOR THE DAYS TO COME?
DO YOU KNOW YET?
>> WE DON'T.
OUR BIGGEST AND FOREMOST IS MAKE
SURE THESE FAMILIES ARE CARED
FOR, THEIR NEEDS ARE MET,
WHATEVER THEY NEED.
LIKE I SAID, YOU KNOW, THANK GOD
WE DID HAVE THIS STAND HERE
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DEAL WITH WHAT WE
DEAL WITH AND WHAT WE'VE BROUGHT
INTO OUR COMMUNITY HAS BEEN
UNBELIEVABLE AND THE OUTPOURING
OF LOVE WITH GOT FROM ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY AND THE SUPPORT
WE'VE GOTTEN.
IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS WE
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO GRIEVE
BUT WE ARE ALSO A STRONG
COMMUNITY.
YOU KNOW, ONE MAN ASKED ME
TODAY, SAID WE WILL BE STUCK
WITH THE STIGMA FOR THE REST OF
OUR LIVES IN UVALDE AS A PLACE
WHERE A SCHOOL SHOOTING WAS.
YOU KNOW, THAT MAY BE TRUE, BUT
WE ARE NOT GOING TO -- WE'RE NOT
GOING TO CHOOSE TO EMBRACE THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO EMBRACE THE
COMMUNITY WE ARE, STRONG,
CARING, AND LOVING FOR ONE
ANOTHER.
>> Sean: MR. MAYOR, I KNOW I
SPEAK FOR THIS AUDIENCE, A LOT
OF LOVE AND PRAYERS IN THESE
VERY, VERY D